the uk has canceled its first
deportation flight to rwanda which was
set to take off on tuesday evening the
flight was canceled after the european
court of human rights intervened ruling
that asylum seekers could face a real
risk of irreversible harm if they were
sent there
the cancellation is seen as a blow to
the government of prime minister boris
johnson who insisted the deportations
would go ahead dw's berget maas has more
from london
the government has really been put under
spots a lot um publicly in the last days
we've had foreign secretary les trust
saying that it's not the
it's not the policy that's immoral but
it's actually the people smugglers it's
those people who help other people
across the channel in boats and that
costs lives and she says this is
necessary as a deterrent because britain
wants to be seen as a country that uh is
is not welcoming uh to to to to too many
people but they want to create um in an
old town that was used years ago a kind
of hostile environment at least towards
what they call illegal migrants now the
people that are crossing the channel are
are people that usually have ties family
ties to britain and that they want to
come to the uk
but they are hoping basically to make it
very very unattractive the uk as a
country because people who who are
coming in in this way who are crossing
by the channel they are now facing the
the possibility of being deported to
rwanda